[Música]
y
buenas
cuando estaba en séptimo grado a mi
curso le agarró la pubertad todas juntas
y empezaron a hacer fiestas todos los
fines de semana en la casa de los padres
que se levantaban
era un pie bastante nerd la verdad que
confiaba mucho en mi cabeza preguntando
mi cuerpo
éramos de los deportes todo esto ha
visto que ese tipo de este tipo de
chicos y bueno también un tiempo era muy
crítico
pero no me voy a quedar quieto pero
igual le gana a la vergüenza todo eso y
no bailaba no me animaba nada mucha
vergüenza
entonces me quedé toda esa época
comiendo sanguchitos mirando el resto de
la gente bailando
después con la forma instalada que pato
no baila fue muy difícil empezar porque
hace un paso evitaba miraba está
bailando claramente no intento de la
secundaria
eso me da mucha vergüenza y después fue
aún peor pero bueno cuando la
impertinencia conoció cuando mis
marquínez ya conoce la percusión forme
un lazo muy pero muy fuerte no paraba de
tocar cualquier cosa no todo el tiempo y
con los dedos
y después de tocar y tocar me di cuenta
de que cuando estás tocando la razón no
puede ser la protagonista no puede ser
todo ambiental no pasa solamente por la
cabeza
porque cuando estás tocando si pensás
demás si analizas demás te equivocas te
vas de tiempo o por ejemplo estás
tocando y te equivocas en algo que es
muy metido que no está en el tóxico que
te equivocás de nuevo porque estas
personas cómo te equivocaste en lugar de
seguir tocando ahí no me quedó otra que
empezar a reconciliarme con la intuición
[Música]
de inmediato
ah
y la presencia de la razón claro e
inmediato
cómo jugamos
[Música]
y qué bien que la pasamos como nos pasa
esto estamos en un momento
pero bueno igual seguir subestimando ese
costado mío durante un buen tiempo
pensaba que era como un hobby no no lo
más importante que hacía y ni tampoco
tenía tanto valor en realidad
recién en la facultad entendí que este
mambo no era solamente mío que
es parte del núcleo del pensamiento
hegemónico occidental
en la antigua grecia hace 2600 años era
por un lado era un lugar hermoso donde
vivir
si no eras mujer o negro no es bueno
pero parece la cantidad de gente pequeña
que disfrutaba ser libre tenía tanto
tiempo libre tenía muy buenas cosechas
había buen clima
tengo tanto tiempo libre que empezaron a
preguntarse más cosas de lo normal y así
nació la filosofía el teatro la física
la biología y gran parte del arte y las
ciencias occidentales
en aristóteles después define al hombre
como un animal racional animal racional
o sea debajo de la razón que da las
pasiones el cuerpo los sentimientos de
empatía
la razón pronto vamos a hacer la
protagonista y juez de toda actividad
humana
esa escala de valores se enquistó en el
sentido común ahora todos pensamos que
las cosas son así por defecto no el
sentido común en general eran parte de
mi aristóteles de hecho con 11 por
ejemplo dice no no aquí lo cual es justo
el punto medio donde se siente red
inteligente bueno lo dijo aristóteles
hace 2500 años
pero a nosotros nos queda como sabiduría
popular bueno esto tiene una fecha
después el catolicismo reforzó la
necesidad de domar al cuerpo y sus
placeres de la culpa y en la modernidad
escribieron libros titánicos con
preceptos muy parecidos aunque sin meter
un dios en la ecuación
después también le vino bien al
capitalismo pensemos que la mayoría de
la mayoría de la gente no trabaja de
algo que les gusta en general es una
actividad calculada osea racionalizada
para para conseguir un bienestar
económico o al menos llegar a fin de mes
pero que nos aleja de nuestras pasiones
más genuinas que en general empiezan
siendo hobbies y después de un tiempo la
gente deja de hacer las 18 en una época
escribía 9 por acá bailaba una época
y después de un tiempo ya dejan de
hacerlo no nos olvidemos que una persona
triste tiende a consumir más para
justamente señales de vacío
pero que otros bichos no genera en el
día a día este paradigma racional
por un lado mirando desde afuera esto
la historia de instagram también
llenando las expectativas y frustrar los
donde no se cumplen justamente hasta
tanto sentó la idea que después no
estamos acá no justamente en
obsesionarnos tanto con la meta que nos
olvidamos disfrutar el camino y lo que
tenemos es el camino más
si nos olvidamos disfrutar solamente
quedan las obligaciones
dije solamente que las obligaciones nos
llamamos estrés
buscamos tanto la vuelta de tuerca que
teníamos pasados de rosca que estresante
no
no estoy diciendo que la razón no tenga
sus virtudes a fin de cuentas vamos toda
esta civilización con esta herramienta
no toda la tecnología todos los cálculos
de matemáticas todo sale de ahí yo digo
que estamos mucho más que eso y tenemos
una tendencia sistemática sobrestimar lo
históricamente también por estas mismas
razones por esta escala de valores
históricamente si pedimos más valor a la
música interpreta la razón que la que
interpreta el cuerpo
fíjese si no en una librería cuántas
cuántos libros de historia de la música
clásica o de rock
las artes elevadas pero cuántos hay de
cumbia de reggaetón o de algún otro
género bailable muchísimo menos
a pesar de que en esta época el
reggaeton se han generado más extremado
o sea más escuchado en todo el mundo
esos basit arias de todo el mundo mayor
reggaeton muy raro
y la cumbia es el género con más
subgéneros de toda latinoamérica
pero casi no hay hay muy pocos registros
de la historia de la documentación
recién ahora empieza a ver por qué se
estaba justamente resquebrajando este
paradigma racional yo creo que a fuerza
de tantos ataques de pánico la gente se
está dando cuenta que necesita más cosas
que solamente estar calculando también
hay muchas opciones maliciosas o de
memes en internet de gente que compara
una música con la otra no típico te
ponen en un tema de serrat y una letra
de daddy yankee viste es tan mala todo
bien pero están buscando cosas distintas
o sea no tiene el mismo objetivo esa
música un tema de daddy yankee no
intenta generarte lo mismo que una obra
de mozart o un tema de spinetta
si justamente la idea es pensar menos
tiene sentido que una obra interpreta el
cuerpo sea relativamente simple y con
lírica simple también porque justamente
no que la idea es buena sacar de esta
parte recrear o relajar un poco la
reflexividad pero bueno esto está esto
está totalmente creo que todos hemos
visto una vez el ejemplo de esto
pero para que una persona justamente que
estuvo nueve horas en la oficina toda la
semana con el cuerpo inerte
y se anime a bailar se anima a relajarse
a conectarse con su propia sensualidad
con su cuerpo tiene que ser medianamente
predecible el tema o directamente un
tema conocido algo que estos que
consiguen su casa entonces puedan fluir
a través de eso
el baile grupal como lo conocemos es una
actividad que empezó hace más de 6000
años mucho más que sócrates la actividad
más popular que
el más popular del mundo justamente para
desconectar para hacer catarsis para
olvidarse de cuánto subió el gas
y relajar las poses y parar un poco
viste con todas las obligaciones que
tenemos en el día a día y millones de
personas
ocurren a esto todos los fines de semana
pero está tan devaluado
o sea estás tan devaluado que ni
siquiera nos preguntamos justamente está
tan en el sentido común evaluado que ni
siquiera nos preguntamos por qué una
sola persona un vecino un maldito vecino
enrique por ruidos molestos puede
sabotear el derecho a catarsis de
decenas o cientos de personas importa
mucho más que esa persona norma bien que
otras personas pueden descargar toda
esta frustración semanal
o también nunca nos preguntamos por qué
carnaval es otra vez al año
al principio bailamos al ritmo de los
tambores en rituales religiosos de hecho
por ejemplo hay evidencias de tambores
de conforme de seve que se encontraban
en la zona de alemania hace 5.000 años o
sea pero realmente hay como en es algo
que se perpetúen en un montón de
culturas milenarias también hay casos en
china en todos lados
ahora hace 60 a 70 años más o menos que
nos juntamos para que nos juntamos a
escuchar música pregrabada al palo en
parlantes que nos hace retumbar todo el
cuerpo esto empezó de jamaica y fue
porque primero las clases bajas a
máquina no podía costear los músicos
envíos
ellos mismos armados los parlantes
poniendo música tan fuerte que hay
testimonios de gente que decía que es
justamente que con los graves vibrando
le él no se tiene el hambre cuando la
música está tan fuerte es justamente
genera una experiencia que física
también te vibra todo el cuerpo
y nos iguala también porque estamos
todos bajo el mismo estímulo presente
presente presente todos bajo el mismo
estímulo igualados por el bombo
el dj en todo este contexto justamente
articula esa maquinaria de estímulos
sonoros toda esa tecnología esta
tecnología los parlantes lo que es como
una especie de nave espacial y la
partícula para generar esos espacios de
catarsis colectiva
por eso mismo el diseño la dj no son los
protagonistas el protagonista el
protagonista en la catarsis que está que
ese momento suceda no que esa catarsis
suceda la salud de la pista de baile por
eso dice es como un chamán urbano de
esta época justamente dirige esta
catarsis colectiva que es milenaria
aunque no necesitamos en esta época
postular dioses del amor ni
y por eso también es un diálogo es un
estado de encuentro
porque la música no es el mp3 el vinilo
o el disco en el que estaba la música
que es el momento en el que sale de los
parlantes y se conecta con la gente que
está escuchando a la gente que está
bailando ese es el hecho artístico
es el momento justamente de liberarse de
quienes somos un rato
por todo esto nos instó a cuidar las
pistas de baile y no sobreestimar las no
sobreestimar nuestros placeres las cosas
que realmente nos gustan no sobrestimar
los rituales colectivos o individuales
que nos permite influir es en calcular
tanto
por qué
somos mucho más que nuestras
obligaciones y cada tanto yo sé que esto
suena redundante pero no sé cuando yo
era chico
me fue muy difícil darme cuenta esto
reconciliarme con lo que normalmente me
va a aplazar la idea de mí era más
fuerte que lo que estaba sucediendo
conmigo en mis propias expectativas
conmigo mismo hasta que finalmente me di
cuenta chiste lo que me gusta con
también otra manera de salir de clase me
causa tristeza una situación típica que
veo como dj este es el típico chabón que
va a la fiesta y sistemáticamente
intenta que alguien le dé bola una u
otra otra vida otra piba ahí están nueve
horas en la oficina
y después sale y sigue trabajando
al tipo relájate un toque aparte costa
si te relajas va a ser todo
más hace más atractivos justamente si te
ves ahí bailando y disfrutando te
van a ser más atractivos y te va a ser
viéndome
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
y la noche me la paso a paso
en las noches me la paso
[Música]
[Aplausos]